bonjour bonjour regarde ton texte
oh mais quelle belle robe en soie tu
portes à temps ce n'est même pas de la
soie merci mais tu me fais penser à la
route du même nom tu sais celle que
marco polo a emprunté un jour et par
laquelle la peste est arrivé dans mon
dernier épisode
faisons un épisode là dessus non c'est
une bonne idée
allons-y
[Musique]
évidemment on ne parlera pas uniquement
de marco polo dans cet épisode ni
uniquement de la route de la soie
le titre était là pour vous attirer mais
d'abord que faut-il pour créer une route
de la soie une route
on y viendra après et de là soit à la
soie est fabriqué depuis plusieurs
millénaires en chine et se popularise
chez les romains à partir du 1er siècle
avant jésus-christ la soif est un peu de
voyages avant d'arriver dans l'empiré
romain
elle est produite sous la dynastie des
ânes et ces derniers en offre aux
nomades zone ue pour qu'ils leur foute
la paix à leur tour l'exemple venu
entrant qu'avec des nomades un peu plus
à l'ouest
et de fil en aiguille elle arrive au
parti qui en vendent aux romains alors
une les roma ne connaissait pas la chine
il l'appelait crs ou tineye ne savais
pas trop ce que c'était 2 il ne savait
pas comment fabriquer la soie et 3 c'est
la junte est ronde cette vidéo pour vous
dire que je trouve cet humour pitoyable
les romains appelle la soie série k et
ça devient rapidement le tissu à mettre
partout en coussin en vêtements comme la
soie coûte super cher à importer à cause
de son coût de production des dangers du
transport et des taxes les romains et
c'est même de l'interdire parce que ça
fait un peu trop d'or qui quittent le
pays juste pour de la soie ouais mais
s'habillait en or c'est chaud
effectivement il y en a qui ont essayé
ils ont eu des problèmes
bref les romains m la soie sans être
capable de la produire
il pense qu'elle vient d'une sorte
d'arbre allen et la production de soie
n'arrive qu'au 6e siècle à
constantinople et au 12e siècle en
sicile sans rentrer dans les détails la
soie est produite à partir des vers à
soie que les chinois élèves sur des
mûriers
du coup tu as parlé la soie met un pas
encore parlé de route bien vu lui les
chinois de la dynastie and dont je
parlais précédemment continuent de
craindre les nomades lille on you dont
je parlais aussi précédemment
du coup ils créent les premières
missions diplomatiques vers l'ouest les
entre en contact avec les indiens les
parts
forcément ces missions sont accompagnés
de marchands parce que c'est toujours
intéressant de se faire un petit peu
d'argent au passage du coup au bout d'un
moment les ânes envoie des ambassades
avec uniquement des marchands et aucun
ambassadeur
je crois que les ambassadeurs sont des
marchands de soi jusqu'au 2ème siècle
après jésus-christ les chinois commerce
donc avec l'occident et des routes
terrestres et maritimes se forment mais
toujours grâce à des intermédiaires
les parts principalement qui préfèrent
éviter qu'il y ait des liens directs
entre les chinois et les romains parce
que pognon les marchandises échangées
sont de l'or de la soie des pierres et
métaux précieux de l'ivoire des perles
du corail c'est en 166 seulement qu'a
lieu la première ambassade romaine en
chine
mais du coup durant l'antiquité les deux
potes le commerce sans trop savoir qui
est qui par exemple les romains pense
que les chinois vivent deux ou trois
cents ans
bah quoi ils ont bien des hommes à tête
de chien là bas on en reparle après ok
à partir du vème siècle la route de la
soie n'est plus emprunter uniquement par
des marchands mais aussi par des
pèlerins notamment des blues east qui
contribue à répondre le bouddhisme en
chine jusqu'en neuvième siècle comme le
bouddhisme intéresse beaucoup les
chinois des pèlerins chinois se rendent
à leur tour en inde pour consulter les
textes et visiter les lieux où aurait
prêché bouddha d'autres religions voyage
grâce à la route de la soie comme le
nestorianisme est considéré comme une
hérésie par l'église mais qui se répand
en perse chez les mongols et en chine au
viiie siècle l'islam arrive en inde et
s'y implantent également mais
revenons-en au marché ouais parce qu'on
attend encore marco polo c'est un peu le
titre de la vidéo
il va arriver un jour pour l'instant on
arrive au neuvième siècle
l' empire romain n'existe plus mais l'
empire mongol a pris le relais et permet
aux routes caravanières de se maintenir
les arabes et les chrétiens continuent
de fréquenter ces routes pour le
commerce principalement même si certains
chrétiens on voit aussi des missions
religieuses
il existe donc toujours des routes
terrestres mais ce sont surtout les
routes maritimes qui sont empruntés
entre le golfe persique et la chine il
faut compter 8 mois pour faire le voyage
aller puis attendre la fin de la mousson
pour repartir
donc le trajet prend largement plus d'un
an les chinois se rendent aussi dans le
golfe persique et tout ce petit monde
commerce se mélangent on découvre la
boussole qu'utilisent les chinois grâce
à certains textes comme la description
des peuples barbares de zaho beaucoup et
on sait que la chine importe et du bois
et des résines aromatiques des
médicaments drogues les parfums des
épices de l'artisanat de l'ivoire de la
corne de rhinocéros
al'inverse les occidentaux acheter de la
soie la porcelaine du camphre du sucre
de la cannelle
lançant les biens commerciaux se
développe progressivement avec la
création de réglementation et de
commissariat à la marine marchande en
chine qui prélèvent des taxes sur
certains produits en occident à partir
des croisades les marchands génois
italien et vénitien se remettent à
utiliser les routes terrestres pour
rallier la terre sainte et ouvrir des
comptoirs en méditerranée par exemple la
famille de marco polo ça y est on y
vient avait une maison de commerce à
constantinople à venise d'où est
originaire marco polo les marches en
s'organisant collègues en za pour s'unir
face à l'adversité et aux risques du
voyage du coup il ya un mec qui finance
le voyage pendant que les autres font le
voyage c'est justement ainsi que
commence le voyage de maffeo et nicolau
paulo le papa de marco en 1260 de venise
il embarque vers leurs comptoirs de
constantinople où ils vendent une
première fois des marchandises puis vers
la crimée ou venise avait aussi un
comptoir marché à partir de là et sans
qu'on sache trop pourquoi ils continuent
à cheval et sans peur ils essaient bien
de rentrer à constantinople à un moment
donné mais la route est coupée à cause
de la guerre du coup il continue encore
il passe trois ans à bout clara en
actuelle ouzbékistan à l'époque aux
mains des mongols de là ils décident
sans prétention d'aller rencontrer le
grand khan kubilaï khan
à partir de là on a complètement mis de
côté l'aspect pognon du voyage il
discute avec leucan qui les charge d'un
message pour le pape et demande qu'ils
lui envoient sens avant pour pas faire
les choses à moitié
afin qu'il lui explique le christianisme
- à l'époque y avait patrick ipdia donc
si tu voulais savoir un truc tu convoqué
sens avant pour contre l'expliquent les
polos repartent donc vers pâques en 1269
mais apprennent en arrivant que le pape
est mort donc en attendant le prochain
habemus papam
il rentre à venise pour retrouver le
petit marco qui a alors 15 ans seulement
habemus papam tout de suite et donc
faute de pape
ils reprennent la route en 1271
lorsqu'ils repartent ils décident
d'emmener le petit marco qui a alors 17
ans ils repartent par acre jérusalem la
liasse et en arrivant là bas ils
apprennent que ça y est le pape a été
élu du coup ils repartent à accra pour y
embarquer deux frères dominicains qui
vont aller expliqué christianisme à
kubilaï khan
ça vaut pas sens avant mais c'est déjà
ça finalement les frères dominicains ont
peur de la guerre et abandonnent en
cours de route pleutre mécréants
il arrive donc près du khan avec
quelques lettre du pape un peu d'huile
sainte
c'est là que marco prend de l'importance
dans le récit puisque al'inverse de son
oncle et de son père il reste au près du
khan et effectué quelques missions à son
service de telles missions confiées à un
étranger n'était pas exceptionnel il
était fréquent pour les empereurs
moghols d'avoir à leur service des
étrangers tels que des turcs des
tibétains des arabes des russes etc
marco polo occupe donc la charge
d'inspecteurs et peut-être d'agents
d'enseignement il est envoyé à travers
le pays pour différentes missions dont
ils ne donnent pas toujours les détails
pendant trois ans il est aussi nommé
gouverneur de la région de yangzhou
il parlait lepers le mongol est
peut-être le turc et l'arabe seulement
au bout d'un moment les polos commence à
avoir assez mouillé leur chemise et
aimerait bien rentrer à venise mais le
calme n'est pas d'accord ils repartent
finalement par bateau en 1291 avec des
ambassadeurs et entreprennent un long
voyage vers sumatra l'iran les côtes
africaines
il débarque dans le golfe persique et
rentre à venise par la turquie
prenant sûrement un nouveau bateau à
constantinople on est alors en 1295 plus
de vingt ans après le début du voyage et
c'est la fin de la partie intéressante
de l'avis de marc où on sait qu'ensuite
il reste marchand mais sans faire partie
du conseil de la ville qui a une femme
des filles une maison qu'il vit
tranquille quoi quand même en 1298 il
est détenu en otage à gênes il dicte ses
mémoires à son pote de prison
rustique celle de pise qui en fait un
best-seller mémorable effectivement un
voyage tels que celui de marco polo
n'est pas exceptionnel pour l'époque
même s'il était rarement le fait de
marchand est plutôt suez de
missionnaires par contre écrire son
récit de voyage pour un marchand ça
c'est bad ass et jamais vu le livre des
merveilles ou deux gisements du monde où
il est mis lyonnais où il faudrait
choisir un titre à un moment donné c'est
tenir est un récit du voyage de marco
polo qui décrit les habitants et des
particularités des pays qu'il a traversé
on y trouve par exemple une description
de la ville d'anjou qui est la capitale
de la dynastie song et une importante
d'une marchande ou encore de caen baluk
la capitale d'hiver du grand khan dans
laquelle il décrit une sorte de papier
monnaie qu'on trouve pas en europe et
c'est dommage quand même si c'était un
peu mieux renseigner sur ces papiers
monnaies et se serait rendu compte que
les billets étaient imprimés et comme
l'invention de l'imprimerie ne se fait
que le siècle plus tard en occident
ça aurait pu lui filer une idée de génie
ou un bon mal de crâne
grâce à lui on sait aussi que les grands
cannes disposait d'un système de poste
et de relais très développés qui courait
surtout son royaume
en vrac parce que ce livre est assez
riche on ne trouve mention de divinités
à plusieurs têtes de certaines cultures
et de comment elles sont pratiquées mais
son livre s'appelle aussi de livre des
merveilles c'est pas pour rien dans ce
type d'ouvragé on trouve des récits de
voyages mais aussi des fables et marco
polo ne va pas se priver de raconter des
fables
il s'est peut être inspiré d'autres
fables célèbres comme le roman
d'alexandre qui était pas mal à la mode
à cette époque en tout cas elle nous
parle donc aussi de créatures étranges
comme la salamandre où les hommes sino
céphale surville en damant ses
descriptions peuvent donc être largement
remise en cause même lorsqu'il n'ya pas
d'intervention de créatures fantastiques
si on veut chercher des témoignages
fidèle des orientaux vu par les
occidentaux
il faut donc chercher ailleurs j'ai le
franciscain gens de planck a repeint par
exemple qui rencontre le grand khan en
1246 et rédige son histoire des mongols
à partir de là dans cette histoire et
mélange des légendes mongole et les
descriptions anthropologique de ces
derniers
la mission de suivante est celle de
guillaume de rubrouck qui rencontre le
grand khan sur ordre de saint louis en
1249 à son retour il rédige son voyage
dans l'empiré mongol qui contient les
informations les plus précises de tout
ce que j'ai cités on y trouve des
descriptions des mongols et des
différents peuples qui l'a rencontré au
cours de son voyage mais aussi des
coutumes de leur habitation etc
au 14ème siècle les relations entre la
chine et le monde chrétien cesse les
deux causes principales sont l'épidémie
de peste qui frappe les deux continents
dans les années 1940 voir l'épisode 16
si vous l'avez manquée et
l'affaiblissement du pouvoir mongols il
faut attendre la fin du xvème siècle
pour que de nouveaux européens surtout
des portugais se rendent en asie lors de
grandes expéditions maritimes
ils se rendent en inde en chine au japon
et permettent d'améliorer les
connaissances géographiques qui n'avait
pas beaucoup évolué depuis le livre des
merveilles de marco polo qui n'était
déjà pour un géographe curistes pas très
folichon genre y avait des montagnes qui
volent et façon avatar quand même les
hommes à tête de chien je veux bien mais
des montagnes qui veulent sérieusement
c'est des foutaises le mec a dû arriver
chez le cannet découvrir les joies de la
drogue dès le premier mois c'est pas
possible autrement
il a enjolivé un peu mais c'est ça aussi
qui fait que sa vie est resté super
connu alors qu'elle n'était pas
exceptionnel non mais c'est plus qu'en
jolivet la balance les images je vais la
raconter sa vie des mères
veille l'histoire commence bien par
marco et sa famille qui quittent leur
ville pour aller explorer le monde
arrivé au pied du can après une longue
chevauchée il lui offre le code du
travail
un livre qui passent plus de deux kilos
mais le cas n'est pas content du tout
parce qu'il voulait sens avant parce
qu'ils osent pas leur dire qui sait pas
lire en fête
en plus le mec est super riches alors
s'il avait voulu un livre qu'il aurait
pu l'acheter tout seul et le faire
livrer plus vite merci
du coup ils envoient marco parcourir le
monde pour avoir la paix pendant ce
voyage
marco décide de prendre son pied quitte
à en perdre la tête il fait pas les
choses à moitié il se fait transporter à
d'autres bébés phacochères la grande
place à un moment elle essaye de monter
une troupe de théâtre contemporain mais
leucan trouve ça trop avant gardiste et
du couple et subventions alors il se
lance dans le concours de caniches l'ofs
puis de dragon qui se cherche un peu
finalement décidément passionnée par les
animaux et se lance dans la chasse à la
licorne
mais un jour ça tourne mal une licorne
fait une tête à queue et décide de
prendre le large
il part vers d'une nouvelle usine et
manque de se faire embarquer par des
hommes sirènes mais leur coût sans leur
disant que c'est pas l'homme qui prend
la mer c'est la mer qui prend l'homme
là il arriva en damant aux griffes des
hommes à tête de chien qu'ils
accueillent plutôt bien puis sortent
leurs habits du dimanche quand ils
apprennent que c'est marco polo et puis
c'est la partie dont il n'aime pas trop
parler
plein de gens à poil on sait pas trop ce
qui s'est passé finalement il donne des
consignes de vote à des gens qui sont
incapables de prendre des décisions pas
romaine et il rentre chez lui après un
petit jacuzzi et c'est ça l'histoire de
marco polo
tout y est
google wave
rodez face à face in mind games terre
ap
m